mais d'abord une découverte scientifique
importante pour la première fois au
monde une équipe de chercheurs
britanniques a réussi à décrypter
presque totalement un chromosome humain
il s'agit du chromosome 22 d'ici au
printemps prochain c'est l'ensemble du
génome humain qui va être ainsi des
chiffres et cela représente un réel
espoir pour la médecine préventive
explications de jean sébastien fernandez
et leur anne berrou les chercheurs qui
ont fait cette découverte peuvent
afficher leur satisfaction car l'étape
qu'ils viennent de franchir est capitale
pour la médecine dans leur long travail
de mise à jour du patrimoine génétique
qui pousse et britanniques ont en effet
décrypter complètement l'un des 23
chromosomes humains le chromosome 22 le
plus petit c'est comme si on avait
établi la cartographie complète d'une
nouvelle planète
on savait que la planète existait on
savait que le chromosome existait on
connaissait quelques éléments sur
quelques gènes mais on n'avait que
quelques informations
maintenant on a une faute au détail et
les chromosomes humains sont porteurs
des gènes ils définissent entre autres
notre sexe la couleur de notre peau et
celle de nos cheveux et aussi certaines
de nos maladies cette découverte est
donc essentiel car le seul chromosome 22
serait à l'origine de 35 pathologies
comme les leucémies cancers
schizophrénie ou encore maladies du
coeur
il s'agit donc d'une avancée
considérable dans la prévention et le
traitement des maladies on va gagner un
temps fou avant par exemple pour décoder
le gène de la schizophrénie on aurait
peut-être mis une dizaine d'années
maintenant avec les informations que
l'on a
ce n'est plus qu'une question de mois en
france l'équipe du professeur vdn bac
qui dirige le centre le plus important
de recherche génétique a accueilli la
nouvelle avec satisfaction mais aussi
prudence tout dispositif qui a été mise
en place du
pas mal d'années déjà commencent à
apporter des résultats est
symboliquement c'est important même si
ce n'est qu'un pour cent du génome c'est
quand même quelque chose de tout à fait
significatif car les chercheurs avancent
très vite au printemps 2000 ils seront
en mesure de dresser une première carte
du génome humain avec en perspective la
multiplication des thérapies géniques